so that's suppose let's just to have it
be one because I'm really curious how
you spend your time and how you how you
organize it so if you have four weeks to
write a first draft for one what's your
work schedule going to be like so my
process is probably a little different
than most people I I write fifteen pages
a day so basically I figure out when
it's due and I back out fifteen pages
per day and I take into consideration if
I've got something going on in the
afternoon like today is not a 15-page
day because I'm I'm with you guys thank
you but I and then I work until those 15
pages are done so if I'm done at 3
o'clock because I had a great writing
day and it went really smoothly
fantastic if it takes me till 9 o'clock
it takes me till 9 o'clock and then
that's when I end my day it helps - it
helps me to do that because I keep on
track and I also don't get caught up in
my own oh my gosh I'm loving this I just
want to keep going because that can
happen too when you're really on a roll
writing you'll I mean I've had that
happen where you just don't eat and you
just keep working through the night and
you're just so excited about what you're
writing that's fine but you can't make a
living living that way right you have I
have relationships and I have people and
dinner to make and things like that and
so I stopped when I this is my way of
doing it I stopped at 15 pages and
that's it and pick back up tomorrow and
start again were you always that precise
with it I mean that's faster yeah it's
kind of it feels very I know that seems
very technical right for something
that's so creative but again like I said
before you have to look at this like a
business right so you have to plan and
organize and figure out what's giving
you the best results and for me this
gave me the best results because I know
at page 11 I only have a few more pages
to do and I can be done and so you know
and at the beginning of every day I
start out and I go okay that's enough
it's a big enough chunk that I'm not
forcing myself to go back and reread
that's a deadly thing that writers do is
they go back and they rewrite themselves
over and over so forces you to keep
moving through and then you do your
rewrite at the end so once once those
110 pages or whatever are done that's
when you that's when I go back and I
build in usually a couple days off
because you need that time away from
it to kind of forget about it a little
bit and then when I come back and I
reread it I give myself two or three
days to do the rewrite and it's just
basically cleaning everything up or
changing at breaks or you know if I've
come up with an idea in between that
time to add then I'll do that that's
great because I mean really in a sense
you want to think that you're your own
boss but really the network is your boss
so you're working for them but you've
also got to monitor yourself so that
sounds like a great way to keep yourself
on track so you're not doing two pages a
day but you're not burning yourself out
right and I think also you can get
obsessed with is the writing good is it
not good do I like this do I not like it
when you have to get those 15 pages done
eventually you have to say screw it I've
got to move on and it forces you to move
on which i think is good for the process
because nothing really good comes from
sitting there obsessing over the same
scene so it is what it is I moved on I
can come back to it and giving yourself
permission to do that I think is very
healthy and I think it's actually good
for the process and the product so now
let's suppose you have three projects
going are you still doing 15 pages it
depends so yes so 15 pages on something
I don't you know some writers will say
I'm going to do 7 pages on this project
in the morning and then 7 pages I don't
do that I say okay this is my I'm doing
15 pages today on this and I'm taking
three days off to work on the next
project and then I come back to it so
that's kind of how I organize it I have
a hard time splitting it up and trying
to work on different multiple projects
in the same day especially at 15 pages I
think if you were doing fewer maybe but
15 pretty ambitious yeah that would
sound difficult if the stories are so
different or you know you just want to
keep the character and all that separate
and you have to split it up and one day
because your mind is good it's worse
when they're actually similar like if
they're both projects for the same
network because or they're both
thrillers because then that's when it
gets confusing it's actually better when
you're doing like a romantic comedy and
then also working on a thriller because
they're so different you don't you don't
mix those characters up at all
you